vient toujours de moscou une information
étonnante a filtré il ya quelques jours
une information qui dépasse les plus
spectaculaires aventures de james bond
les diplomates américains en poste à
moscou sont en effet presque tous
atteints de nausées détour ni cement et
selon des rumeurs non confirmées
deux d'entre eux seraient même frappé de
leucémie c'est l'aboutissement d'une
véritable escalade de l'espionnage
électronique les américains à partir de
leur ambassade à moscou avait réussi par
des moyens électroniques à capter les
conversations entre dirigeants
soviétiques lorsque ceux-ci communiqué à
bord de leur voiture
la réaction des services secrets
soviétiques a été je simplifie celle de
l'arroseur arrosé
ils ont en effet monté autour de
l'ambassade américaine une sorte de
filet de protection qui renvoyait sur
l'ambassade sous forme d'hyper fréquence
les ondes qui on partait sur cette
histoire véritablement extraordinaire
une explication de michel chevalet à
moscou s'est joué en quelques sorte en
trois actes actes premier à l'ambassade
des états unis à moscou
on a truffé le toit du bâtiment
d'antenne cette bonne guerre pour
écouter les communications radio
électrique des soviétiques
c'est de l'espionnage bien sûr et
notamment dit on les communications
radio avec les voitures officielles
acte 2 réponses et soviétique puisque
les américains nous écoutent et bien
nous allons faire du brouillage c'est à
dire que sur le toit des bâtiments les
soviétiques ont installé des antennes
pour brouiller les communications des
américains acte 3 réponses des
américains bien puisque les soviétiques
ne brouille
nous allons installer de nouvelles
antennes pour dominer en quelque sorte
brouillage donc les américains ont fait
dans la surenchère
enfin acte iv le dernier rail qui s'est
joué durant le mois de février les
soviétiques vexé d'être déjoué par les
américains ont dit et bien puisqu'on ne
peut pas supprimer les antennes nous
allons supprimer l'électronique esso à
distance comment eh bien ils ont
installé sur le toit des bâtiments
des antennes en forme de coupole les
antennes qui émettent en direction du
bâtiment des ondes hiver fréquence c'est
ce qu'on appelle des micro ondes et
saison dont la propriété de pénétrer à
l'intérieur du bâtiment est en quelque
sorte de saturer de neutraliser
l'électronique
or malheureusement dans cette affaire
les rues selon me qu'on veut dire le
paquet à telle enseigne que le personnel
de l'ambassade a été pris de nausées de
vomissements d'étourdissements c'est à
dire qu'il était victime des micro ondes
et 6 qui a révélé la faire au grand
public
alors pourquoi sommes-nous ici aux arts
ménagers et bien parce que précisément
l'effet de ces micro-ondes sur les
organismes vivants d'organismes
biologiques et bien on le trouve dans
des fours que l'on appelle four à micro
ondes et qui chauffent les aliments
justement par l'action de ces
micro-ondes
comme quoi vous voyez finalement que
dans la science et bien il ya toujours
deux volets d'un côté bien l'espionnage
et de l'autre côté il ya si je peux dire
les cuisines